need motivation watch a top 10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well you have Michael
Jordan level talent add something so get
ready to be confident stop saying I
can't and find the right mentors with
Dan lock and my take on his top ten
rules of success volume 14 to give you
the confidence motivation and believe
that you need okay let's take it off
with rule number one don't use hope as a
strategy the most dangerous word that
you could use day-to-day is the work
hope hope this word keeps you poor think
about it when I talk to you entrepreneur
when I asked him so what exactly is your
marketing strategy they might say
something like well Dan my marketing
strategy is I build my business through
word of mouth through referrals and
always we apply you mean hope you see
hope it's not a strategy
most people they hope to grow their
business they hope to get referrals they
hope to generate more income they hope
to have more free time they hope to
start their business they hope they'll
get bank financing for the investments
they hope hope it's not a strategy you
see successful people we don't use hope
as a strategy because the minute you use
the word hope what you're saying is you
have no power you have no control over
the outcome why I hope it works I hope
this works out
now it's one thing to say hey I hope you
liked this video that's okay but
whenever you say I hope I when you give
away that responsibility you also give
away their power you have no control you
have no choice when you have no choice
when you have no control when you have
no power when you cannot decide you
cannot take action and you cannot make
that happen
number two know how to close Michael
Gerber from emails talks about this
most people they actually not
entrepreneurs they are technicians
suffering from an entrepreneurial
seizure meaning that they are very good
at the technical work at the thing but
they don't understand how the business
works they do not know how to sell see
the number one skill that you need as an
entrepreneur as a business owner is the
ability to close if you don't close
sales you will not bring in revenue and
with no revenue you don't have a
business and yet most people they get
into business without developing that
skill set most people don't know how to
communicate fewer know how to sell
almost no one knows how to close when
you can close anyone at any time
it means that you have the ability to
generate revenue at any moment then you
can create revenue for your company and
that is the number one skill that you
need to make sure that your business is
successful rule number three be
confident successful people are
confident in their abilities you see the
two biggest enemies to success number
one self doubt number two fear of the
unknown we struggle with self doubt we
worry are we ready for this are we good
enough do we actually have what it takes
to succeed confidence is nothing more
than believing in yourself and believing
in yourselves is nothing more than doing
the things that you once didn't believe
that you could do you see confidence
comes from competence it's easy to
believe in yourself when everyone
believes in you that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about
believing in yourself when you're not
ready believing yourself when no one
believes you believe in yourself when
everyone tells you that you cannot do it
then you cannot make it that you don't
have what it takes that is when you need
to develop that unshakable
self-confidence that believe that you
can do it and confidence is not the same
as arrogance the arrogance is thinking
that you above everybody else confidence
is knowing that no one
is above you do you feel confident
enough in your own abilities that you
can do what it takes are you willing to
bet on yourself not just words but
action how often you invest in yourself
are you willing to put everything you
have on the line for your goals and for
your dreams do you bet on yourself or do
you procrastinate do you hesitate
are you perfectionist do you suffer from
paralysis analysis rule number four stop
saying I can't I can do it right I can i
I don't have time or I can't afford it
is the minute you use the word can't
your brain stops working stops looking
for solutions the minute years I can't
well that's it I can't do it right it
robs you of your potential it wraps you
off the possibility instead ask yourself
how can I see when people say to me why
I can't start my business or I can't
give up the high income skill oh I can
do that side hustle oh I can't whatever
I always tell them does that mean that
you don't want to do it or does that
mean you don't know how to do it because
we all have the ability we can all do
something if we want to
could you do it if you really really
really want to of course you could so
the question is it's not I can't
is either you don't want to and that's
perfectly fine then don't say I can't
just say I don't want you when your
friends ask you to go out it's just wow
you know I can tonight don't say I can't
just say you know what I've got other
commitments I don't want to go just tell
them I don't want to go this is not
something I want to do or maybe next
time right it's side commit when you say
well I can't does that mean you don't
know how to do it because you could go
get the how - there's so much how to you
on the internet you could go find a way
you can you can take a program go to
this van learn from a mentor do is
something you have the ability so we
place that word can't with either how
can i or hey you know what i can do it i
can start that business
I can learn that skill I can learn from
a mentor right I can quit that job I can
go on a vacation you have got so much
more potential if you just believe in
yourself also if you want to have more
confidence check in my 254 series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below that's a problem with
young people you're not good at anything
oh good no tell me the truth you're not
good at anything after you practice
martial art you develop this natural
self confidence not cockiness but you
develop this natural self confidence
remember this your business is always a
reflection of you rule number five
invest in yourself first listing for
example that you want to start a Shopify
store yes it kind of doesn't cost you a
lot but inventory costs you money so you
invest the last few thousand dollars you
have you go or in into this particular
venture hopefully that it will work my
question is what if it doesn't work what
if the product doesn't sell you put all
your life savings the little bit of
money that you have into it and then now
what what do you do where do you go from
here you see instead of doing that and
then putting all your eggs in one basket
the best thing you can do is start
investing in yourself first
invest in a skill set that you can
deliver to the marketplace in exchange
of money this dramatically lowers your
risk and then when that is working then
you can start your business rule number
six embrace failures successful people
embrace failures do you embrace failures
or do you take failures personal you see
successful people they are ridiculously
positive about the future they always
speak positively about their future
where things are going as if it's
already happened even though there's no
way that it could happen they believe in
themselves whether they have positive
expectations about the
future wall Disney was fired by a news
editor saying that he had no imagination
and no creativity Steven Spielberg was
rejected three times by film school
before getting his huge break Colonel
sander at the age of 56 got rejected a
thousand times for its recipe before a
restaurant picks it up you will notice
the most successful people in any field
they are usually the ones who have
failed
more than anybody else you see the
difference between a successful person
and everyone else it's not a lack of
strength it's not a lack of knowledge
it's a lack of will wisdom Churchill
said it best success is going from
failure to failure without losing
enthusiasm rule number seven get more
customers you want to get more customers
we all want more customers so we can
generate more revenue now it depends on
your business type you might have a
two-step process meaning you may not get
a customer directly it may not be a
direct sales scenario it could be a
two-step process where you actually
generate a lead maybe generate a lead
online and then you convert that lead
into a sell right it's a two-step
process so you have the lead generation
process and then you have the conversion
process it doesn't matter the bottom
line is that's what you focus on that's
what most entrepreneurs focus on how do
I get more customers the challenge is if
you have been in business for any length
of time that the biggest payoff
sometimes their highest paid leverage
points that you have with the business
may not be getting more customers
because it costs us a lot of money to
acquire customers nowadays right when
you're running traffic when you're doing
any kind of advertising it costs a lot
of money to acquire that first initial
customer if you are a startup yes then
focus on getting customers because you
need customers to survive but if you
have been in business for a while then I
want you to consider some of the other
ways to increase your revenue to grow
your business rule number eight beyond
the right
what I'm doing right now right this path
is it gonna get me there right if you
are working at a minimum weight job and
you say you want to make six-figure a
year you want to make you know a quarter
million dollars a year well what are the
chances of whatever you're doing right
now that would get you there right and
if not doesn't matter what you do it's
just that's the wrong path because this
path would never get you there
rule number nine find the right mentors
when you're watching someone's video
when you are following someone on social
media to me that is learning but that's
not mentorship mentorship is much more
intimate it's much more special it's not
just watching someone passively so to me
that there are a lot of people that you
can learn from and I learned from a lot
of people over the years I mean I read
so many books and attend so many
workshops and and every lunch and dinner
and and all these people that are
business people that are interact with I
learned from them I hear their stories I
hear their struggles I hear about the
best practices however when it comes to
mentoring when it comes to having a
mentor I've only had really not up to
this point in my life three mentors in
my life first one his name is Alan Alice
my very first mentor he taught me
marketing and copywriting right if
you've watched my video you know that
second and it's been my mentor since I
was 20 in my early 20s Amy meet my
opportunity right - - to work for him
for one year for the next enough that
Willie is working for free but I learned
a tremendous amount from him and he gave
me the opportunity he he gave me
a chance right he believed in me when no
one believed in me
my second mentor and Pena the fifty
billion dollar man right you may have
seen him on on YouTube in fact I'm going
to visit him in in Scotland in a couple
months and he was here if you saw my
videos my interview with him so he's
been my mentor for more than a decade
now that's my second mentor and my third
mentor my new mentor mr. Duane doing
Clark and doing is a super super
successful man with with great values
and so that's my third mentor so really
I learned from everybody but when it
comes to selecting the right mentor I'm
very very selective I want to pick
someone that I could learn from for a
long time because most people when they
pick someone they see someone on YouTube
they see someone on you social media I
won't live with that person I wonder if
I'm that person only from their person
well the problem with that approach is
think of it like martial art imagine you
are learning you're taking a lesson a
you want to learn boxing this week next
week and you learn Brazilian jiu-jitsu
and then the week after you learn
Chinese kung-fu in it and then the next
month you learn something else you never
get good at it you never never get good
at anything because you're jumping from
one thing to another makes sense and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is value
yourself look for free are you idiot
[ __ ] well that's one way to handle it
when someone asked us to work for free
or can I pay you later when you get
results for them but you can do it
better than that you can deal with our
objection with finesse he would of the
day comment below what's the word
finesse it's like Tai Chi you want to
redirect don't fight force with force
redirect now remember I used to get this
objection quite a bit when I was younger
when I was just starting out in my
career right when I don't have a track
record then people would ask me well Dan
I would I would pay you
later when I get results on this let's
try this out or can you work for free
like what the am I like a volunteer
right my business person here so what do
you do when you get that kind of
rejection so I'm gonna give you a couple
ways to handle this okay if you enjoy
this video give me a thumbs up remember
if you watch a lot of my other videos I
think you'll love this video as well so
here we go number one it's easier to
handle that with some kind of a metaphor
and some kind of a question right a
series of questions and pick a picture
in their mind so when they say hey so
can you work for free you might say
something like hey mr. prospect let me
ask you a question here let's say you
want to buy a Porsche and you walk up to
a Porsche dealership and you say you
know what I want to take this Porsche
home and I'm gonna drive drive it for a
month and just see how I like it
right and then maybe come back and maybe
I'll pay you now if you are the the car
dealership you're the owner of this car
dealership what are you gonna say to
your prospect like that well I'm gonna
say no that's not how it works oh no
you're like it's stupid idiot exactly
right so that's a very powerful way of
using a metaphor to handle it another
way that I've used a metaphor that's
kind of an interesting one I would say
hey mr. prospect let me ask you a
question have you ever eaten a
restaurant before Yeah right so can you
walk up to the restaurant owner and say
hey you know what I'm gonna have I'm
gonna have the meal here and after the
new I'm gonna go home I'm not gonna pay
I'm gonna go home and see how I do in
the bathroom let's see how much how I
like it what kind of power movement I
have and then when I come back I'll see
if I want to pay is it how it works no
that's not how it works at all right
like so there are different ways you can
handle in a in a in a sarcastic but also
firm and respectful way basically
telling them indirectly that you value
your time you're telling your prospect
that you value your skills and expertise
right now in the beginning maybe you
do you have to do a little bit of work
pro bono to get some experience that's
not what I'm talking about here we're
talking about closing and asking for
money up front right we're signing a
deal we're signing an agreement and
we're trying to close a deal right here
or right now now I've got a special
bonus clip from Dan on how to have even
more confidence that I think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go question number
one what are three activities you can do
to help you value yourself more number
two what do you need to stop saying I
can't - and number three who are two
mentors you've learned from that you
need to surround yourself more with now
if you like this video and you're gonna
take some immediate action after
watching it give me that hash tag
believe down in the comments as well a
confident person comes from the point of
view I can learn from everybody what can
I learn from this person their community
be a humble they're learning okay
wow that person's motive I can learn
from everybody not try to compete and
all this stuff like just just learn
right this person getting more results
what can I learn from this person right
not just coming from all insecurity in
populations or I'm so good at this in
there it's not about that kind of stuff
so confidence why is this such a such a
powerful persuasion secret because get
this staying edge using edge a lot of
certainty the marketplace I'll set this
on YouTube I'll share that with you
again most of the time for what we're
selling with selling certainty whether
they'll be in an uncertain world we are
selling certainty in an uncertain world
don't care what product services you're
selling I was thinking about this is
very critical
we're selling certainty in an uncertain
world and part of how you could give
people certainty
y-you feel confident about what you
offer you feel confident about the
results you can produce about the work
that you do about a value deliver about
the impact you could have that's
confidence
most of our no self Moloch's low
confidence or no confidence because the
stuff is not good they're not good at
what they do they don't deliver that
value they don't deliver results of
course you know of course you have no
confidence hi this is Dan Locke if
you're a fan of Evans work if you want
to know exactly how the model my success
I want to invite you to join me for a
special online training all you have to
do is click on a link below you can join
me for absolutely no charge so click a
link below and I will see you in class
and if you want more Dan lock check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
the more I try to chase them on I want
to make the money I want to make the
money then you can see these people
they're so desperate they don't make
money you don't make money if your life
stinks it's your fault